[Music]
the United States ranks dead last in the
world in terms of the support that it
gives new parents after having a baby
it's just fact of the top 18 economies
in the world the United States is the
only country that does not allow for any
paid leave at all so we do have unpaid
leave which is a little bit of a
misnomer people think oh well you can
get parental leave your dad your mom you
can take time well you can if you can
afford it so first of all only 56% of
American workers qualify for FMLA
because of the stipulations you have to
be at a company that has 50 employees
you have to have worked full-time for a
year you have to be working within a
certain radius of your company's home
base so that automatically disqualifies
a lot of people but then when you look
at who can actually afford to take 12
weeks of unpaid leave per child
the numbers go down even further and
what you end up with is that 25 percent
of new American mothers go back to work
less than two weeks after having had a
baby which is just so markedly different
from how it is in the rest of the world
and I think a lot of people think
erroneously that it would be really
costly for our country to have some sort
of paid leave program but when you look
at the other top performing economies in
the world these other countries that
have first of all they have parity
between moms and dads they have you know
the same leave for adoptive parents they
have all kinds of things that just make
this about actually helping produce the
next generation in a way that will make
that generation go on to also support
the economy so in Norway Norway is
consistently ranked as the happiest
country in the world wonderful that
makes sense they have almost a year of
paid leave moms and dads are allowed to
share it sounds great but when you look
at the economy they are also with the
top producing their GDP is the highest
per capita of any top economic country
in the world it's it's kind of amazing
and on top of that they have more moms
who work than any country in the world
they also have more moms
work full-time which is a really
important distinction it's not just that
they have you know mothers really
involved in the workplace they have
mothers who are really involved in the
workplace are also incredibly happy have
also taken this time away from their
jobs and somehow the economy is still
moving forward at a good clip this is so
far away from what we have in the United
States it's it's almost it's sad but
it's almost laughable the women I
interviewed told me that they felt
better kind of more back to normal
physically at about the 5.5 month mark
after having a baby and I was careful to
define that as not necessarily back in
your pre-pregnancy jeans that's not what
I meant it's really more about feeling
comfortable in your skin so that's a the
5.5 month mark on average for all these
women and these were women who had kind
of all approaches to career and
motherhood there were single moms
adoptive moms there were mothers who
worked an hourly wage working jobs and
more professional jobs really as broad a
spectrum of approaches as I could find
and so these women reported feeling back
to normal physically after five point
five months emotionally it was actually
a little longer it was five point eight
months which is really interesting
because when you look at the science of
what a good parental leave looks like it
is six months of paid leave because
according to the research that's been
done six months is the point at which a
mother is much less likely to suffer
from a postpartum mood disorder or
anxiety disorder that is also six months
of paid leave as the protective amount
for baby's health and babies who have
had mothers who have been able to take
that amount of leave paid are much more
likely to be vaccinated on time are
actually less likely to have ear
infections and respiratory infections
it's been shown which sounds really
specific but it is actually due to their
mother's ability to breastfeed longer
which and I'm very much a fed is best
kind of person however you feed your
baby great I just want you to be able to
make the choices that are best for you
so so basically all of the science shows
that it takes at least six months to
start really feeling normal again and
that's because you are hormonal your
body has been through the most enormous
change anybody could go through and yet
you were expected to be back on the job
just the way you were before so yes
unfortunately we and the we is not me
the we is our greater society and
culture undervalues parents in the
workplace particularly moms
[Music]